[Aplausos]
cómo reaccionas cuando tienes miedo
yo
corriendo cuando era pequeña tenía
muchísimo miedo a las inyecciones parece
un miedo tonto pero el miedo real y el
imaginario se siente igual
tenía tanto miedo a las inyecciones que
de verdad salía corriendo del hospital o
de mi casa
cuando tenía que vacunar meo tenía que
recibir una inyección cada 21 días
buscaba la forma de salirme corriendo de
ahí y mi familia iba detrás de mi
alcanzarme
afortunadamente terminó el tratamiento y
creí que solamente yo tenía miedo y que
solamente los niños teníamos miedo
pero después me di cuenta de que no era
así
mi mamá enfermo
fue diagnosticada con cáncer de mama
mi mamá la mujer de ropa oscura a la
izquierda
y dos de sus hermanas también y me di
cuenta que ellas también tenían miedos
miedos muy diferentes míos muy grandes
una de ellas era golpeada por sumario
y cuando le dijo que sospechaba algo
malo en su seno
le comento que
era muy
que era muy fácil que le gustaba que la
vieran y que la tocaran que por eso iba
al médico y entonces ella por miedo a
ser golpeada
dejo que eso pasara
la otra de sus hermanas tuvo mucho miedo
a que se le cayera el cabello
y a perder un seno
y la última a pesar de lo que le dijo al
médico a pesar de que le dijo que no era
nada malo insistió y fue la única que
salvó su vida pero ahí no termina la
historia
dos más de sus hermanas fueron
diagnosticadas también después con la
misma enfermedad y fueron
tuvieron tanto miedo
que decidieron no hacer nada
y en sus palabras decidieron morir con
dignidad y así pasó no sé si haya pasado
así literal como ellos lo dijeron con
dignidad no no lo sé pero al final cinco
estuvieron enfermas y sólo a uno
solo una de ellas pudo sobrevivir
eso me impresionó demasiado
y justo en este momento
fue cuando el miedo más grande de mi
vida
era el sinónimo de la palabra cáncer
y en el 2015
en el 2015 estaba en la sala de hospital
escuchando el mismo diagnóstico me
habían diagnosticado también cáncer de
mama y no podía creer
perdí el cabello perdí las cejas perdí
las pestañas había perdido a mi mamá a
mis días había perdido ambos senos pero
curiosamente
también perdí mis complejos antes del
diagnóstico
me sentía muy insegura
y después
había logrado verme sin máscaras había
logrado ver más allá de esa imagen
me ame como era deje de juzgarme porque
cuantas veces no nos juzgamos somos muy
amables con los demás pero a veces somos
muy crueles con nosotros mismos
decidí
que quería vivir me encanta la vida
tengo una familia increíble
decidí que quería vivir
y me enfrenté también al miedo del
tratamiento
pasaron 16 quimioterapias
y curiosamente
cuando estaba en la sala de hospital
esperando la primera de mis 25
radiaciones conocí a una mujer se acercó
a mí para pedirme que moviera mi bolsa
me lo pide un tono pues no muy amable
levante la mirada
y entonces
ella sonrió
como si nos conociéramos pero la verdad
yo no la recordaba es una mujer muy
enferma
mientras seguía hablando porque
obviamente me dio vergüenza decirle que
pues no no la conocía
esta mujer
me parecía muy cercana y si la había
conocido anteriormente en esta junta
donde yo no quería hablar con nadie
absolutamente con nadie porque me daba
mucho miedo escuchar más historias
negativas tristes que yo ya había vivido
anteriormente en mi familia entonces la
recordé y si me había contado que tenía
tres hijos la más pequeña de dos años
exactamente tenía mi edad en ese momento
le pregunté que cómo estaba
me dijo que el cáncer había avanzado
se había ido al cerebro
y a los huesos
nos pusimos a llorar las dos
como si nos conociéramos desde antes a
pesar de que nada más nos habíamos visto
en una en una ocasión anterior
y ahí
cuando me llamó el médico para pasar
no supe qué hacer con ese teléfono que
me había notado
me lo dio para que le llamara pero la
verdad yo no quería ya saber nada del
tema estaba asustadísima yo ya no quería
conocer más historias y la de ella no
pintaba muy bien
pero bueno decidí enfrentarme a ese
miedo
decidí enfrentarlo porque creí que valía
la pena
y nos hicimos
nos hicimos grandes amigas
en esta imagen
estábamos celebrando precisamente en sus
quinces los 15 en radiaciones entonces
fue algo muy bonito porque yo trataba de
huir trataba de no conocer a gente que
tuviera ese diagnóstico porque pensaba
que iban a hacer historias terribles que
me iban a hacer sentir todavía más mal y
curiosamente obtuve algo muy distinto
conocí a personas extraordinarias todas
ellas eran alegres tenían un amor por la
vida impresionante que yo no había
notado en ninguna otra persona sana
formamos un grupo muy cercano
jessica estaba feliz y cuando se podía
pues nos veíamos
pero las cosas fueron avanzando y llegó
un punto en el que jessica
ya no podía caminar
la fui a ver a su casa nos abrazamos
reímos
nos dijimos cosas muy bonitas
y después su mamá me avisó que ella sí
que había muerto fue una pérdida enorme
para mí
pensaba en su hija
en la más pequeñita
pensaba en sus dos adolescentes
y me preguntaba
porque yo
tenía esa oportunidad que ya no había
tenido porque generalmente cuando nos
pasa algo malo siempre nos preguntamos
por qué a mí
pero cuando le pasa algo malo a alguien
jamás nos preguntamos por qué a mí no
que nos hace tan especiales para que a
nosotros no
entonces me sentí de verdad en deuda con
la vida
porque yo tenía esa oportunidad que ella
y las otras mujeres no habían tenido
y conocí a emma una mujer
que había pasado por el cáncer de mama
pero tenía 38 años como sobreviviente
era la primera historia que yo veía
tan esperanzadora
me animo muchísimo y entonces pensé por
qué no otras mujeres van a saber de
estas historias porque solamente
contamos lo peor
porque no contamos también lo bueno
y ella me inspiró y así como a mí me
espero yo quería inspirar a alguien más
a que pudiera tomar el miedo y
transformarlo en algo positivo
conocí a mujeres extraordinarias de
verdad como mariana que ella salía a la
calle sin peluca súper segura seguía
practicando ballet
seguía
haciendo todo lo que le gustaba
sin miedo a ser juzgada sin miedo a las
miradas
porque cuando uno no tiene cabello
es el centro de atención pero ya no le
importaba y me encantaba lo que veía
así juntos hicimos una exposición que
estuvo en paseo de la reforma
en la alameda y en la explanada del
auditorio nacional
mostrando estas historias
que rompían el mito de que cáncer es
sinónimo de muerte porque ahora no es
así
así como hay casos malos también los hay
los buenos pero esos casi no los vemos
conocí a algunas mujeres jóvenes desde
los 24 hasta los 42 años con las que
trabaje
estuvimos haciendo algunas exposiciones
con la intención de romper mitos y tus
relacionados con la enfermedad que
dificultan la detección oportuna
en el caso de hoy era una mujer que no
había tenido antecedentes familiares
en una mujer joven
ya había sido diagnosticada
el caso de magra
una mujer que había sido detectada
cuando estaba embarazada cuando se cree
que no es así
hay gente que cree que el embarazo
protege
otro mito muy común
o el caso de él
una mujer que había logrado reconstruir
su vida después del cáncer
mucha gente cree que después del
tratamiento ya no hay vida
y ahí está ella y aquí estoy yo
hay posibilidades por eso muchas mujeres
dejan de tratarse o de hacerse un
estudio pensando que si llegan a ser
diagnosticadas con cáncer de mama se
acabó todo cuando no es así
y esta foto me encanta
por qué
justo habla de la importancia de
transformar los miedos
qué se puede hacer con algo tan poderoso
que te puede arrancar la vida o incluso
y transformarla en amor
en esta exposición pasaron cosas
interesantísimas se sumó gente
que solamente
pasaba por ahí pero otra que de verdad
se involucró
había artistas plásticos del valle de
toluca y de la ciudad de méjico
que aportaban una pieza intervenida para
la exposición
la exposición se llamaba tatuaje sin
tinta y estuvo en el museo universitario
lo vuelto leopoldo flores
en este museo pasaron cosas
extraordinarias llegaba
el hombre que traía a su esposa y al
otro día atraía a su hermana y al otro
día
para ella
a una amiga o incluso venían los niños
con las mamás a decirle a su mamá ya te
hiciste la fotografía ya te hiciste el
ultrasonido pasaron cosas que de verdad
a todas nos causaban mucha alegría la
gente que tenía mucho miedo de hacerse
un estudio veía que no era
necesariamente la muerte lo que le podía
esperar en caso de que saliera positivo
y empezaron a tomar acción
cómo queda
todas las mujeres a quien mandaron una
pieza una pieza usada a un brasier
para realizar una instalación
y curiosamente yo puse la campaña en
facebook con mis conocidos y empezaron a
llegarme cajas de veracruz de monterrey
donde ellos ponían sus stand y hacían
esa colecta sin que nosotros les
hubiéramos pedido la gente se sumó al
proyecto
logramos una instalación una instalación
de 500 brassieres que representaban el
número de mujeres que pierden la vida
cada mes en nuestro país a causa del
cáncer de mama
fue un trabajo conjunto donde todas
transformamos ese miedo enorme que
teníamos en algo más
yo me sentía en deuda con la vida
y era mi manera de hacer algo
de no correr de no vivir de intentar
hacer con eso que yo he vivido y mi
familia también
de hacer algo
ellas también lo hicieron y juntas
pudimos construir algo mucho más grande
que nosotras
y bueno esta es mi historia
estos son mis miedos pero yo te quiero
preguntar cuáles son los tuyos
cuántas veces has dejado de hacer algo
por miedo
cuántas veces has dejado de hablarle a
esa persona por miedo a ser rechazado
cuántas veces has dejado de intentarlo
por miedo al fracaso o equivocarte
todos tenemos miedos lo importante es lo
que hacemos con ellos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]